um
i think we're live
i think we're live
we're live
okay
roon
level one
challenge
oh
my headset's already [ __ ] up that's
not good okay
wretch
level one baby
no leveling no summons no nothing
just pure
weapon upgrades
and getting good
and talismans
you know
pretty easy
giga
giga chad
yeah yeah yeah
um
this is a decision actually
um
[Music]
i can find as many seeds as i need out
in the world
i'm gonna yeah
man i don't think this medallion is
gonna do much
but it's probably the most helpful
throughout the entire thing
or at least in the beginning
giga chad
can't believe how accurate this is
all right
so
the first bit of it
is probably just going to be
gathering materials to upgrade
and weapons that we want
hi glenn how are you man
yeah a lot of upgrades
and just
trying to get stuff that we need to not
die
so fast
hello bill all is well man good morning
hope all is well with you too
i'm straight up not even gonna try to
fight this thing at the beginning
giga chad
okay
you know i've never questioned like who
is this
who's this woman
woman
okay
[Music]
almost had it
i guess i should try and fight this
thing why not it kills me it kills me
this thing is wicked hard to fight
though
i also just realized i don't have a hud
come on
ah
i'm dead yep
i need to remember to turn my hud back
on
yes i can use talismans i just can't
physically level
if that makes sense
but i can use talismans
are gonna be great
lag
this man's got some ass
[Music]
you mean that guy at the beginning no
i died
because i'm bad
but yeah this level right here will
never change from one
i can use talismans and stuff
which is fair
what do i get for killing this guy right
here
i have no idea actually
killing tree center right now
oh man
that would be pretty giga chad though
huh
oh
i don't know if i want to kill him
yeah if i don't get anything for it then
like what's the point
okay i'll try the tree sentinel for a
minute
okay
it's gonna be ridiculous
that was probably way too early but
let's get it
lag
oh god
lag
lag
blame it all in the lag
oh god whoa
ow
oh [ __ ] i just thought of this should we
keep track of deaths
i don't even think of that until just
now
it's going to be so much though
we're going to die so much
lag
thank you chat
that was clearly lag
not me being bad
i'll try a few more times
giga chad
oh
oh i need to heal immediately okay
is there a way to cheese this guy
can i like eat him off a cliff
he killed a goat
how dare you
okay
one more time
i think he's trying to kill you
now
nah
he's just uh confused
yeah you guys can keep track of bets
cheating
he's cheating
i stand
stagger
cheating
clearly using hacks
of some kind
oh also i can't use torrent in any fight
that that's another part of this
challenge
it's got to be straight up
okay one more time because i find this
fun
we just do this all day
[Music]
holy lag man
fix your frames game
wow
frames
braves
i don't know how that missed
cheating
not fair
not fair
well where you going
lag
it's so bad in this fight
his armor has too many pixels
there it is
you only hit him once though
what
ow
oh yeah i'm not gonna i'm really not
gonna need any fp flash in my
took five hours to kill him at level one
hmm
i mean we could go get a bunch of
upgrades
we can go get the uchi katana bro
we can run there
but do we just be a degenerate and try
and beat this guy all day
because we could do that
that is a thing
because if i go get the uchi katana i
would be like nah you didn't do it
properly
not like a giga chad would
that attack is so weird
okay
sick combo
not going well so far
i hopped over it oh
i don't know i don't know
i don't know
there it is
i should load up like a strong attack
there huh
probs props
see i hop over that before but that time
it don't work
cheating
[Music]
oh
right
i recommend staying at his butt
so i can sniff it
true
okay one more time
how many times am i gonna say one more
time
at least one more time
we gotta try at least one more time
that was stupid
on my part
i don't i feel like the rain really
doesn't help us here
in terms of frame rate
i swear i press roll and maybe i didn't
have stamina
but my boy just did not move
like at all
but we could go get an uchi katana and
just have a great time here
but i gotta try at least one more time
see why am i waiting there
stay
stop it
ow
that hurt
yeah
we're gonna move on
i will legit be here for like five hours
trying to do this
we'll come back
die
okay that's embarrassing
come here little goat
stop rolling
thank you
no reason for that at all
me
[Music]
that would be a fun challenge in and of
itself though don't you think
just trying to beat him with just this
club
i didn't realize sonic the hedgehog was
in this game
i don't know why i sat down
i am carly
and i can also let you know
i am carly
i am carly
i get from you
nothing i need right now
crafting kit
is gonna be important later but right
now not so much
we're gonna go get torrent we're gonna
go get the ochi katana we're gonna go
get that dagger
from the guy near patches
[ __ ]
we'll need that for later
we're gonna go get
materials
from the cave like right next to here
probably a bunch of other caves
we're gonna do this smart
no i actually won't fight patches
i won't go in the cave it's right
outside
patches is a nerd dude
nerd
he's a jerk
i offer you a honda accord
i'm afraid you have no [ __ ]
um
no
actually one time
another time
i did randy and then i was the flame of
frenzy lord of frenzy
and now we're here
as giga chad as you can see
i just straight up told her no
okay
we at least have torrent though
wait do i have to accept her to get
torrent
damn it
i thought it'd be funny to say no
give me my honda accord
yes
what if there is a challenge where you
can't use torrent at all you have to run
everywhere
can you imagine
how annoying that would be
okay where do we go now
up
storm penis what
run failed using torrent
i can't use torrent in a fight
i like how on youtube you guys have like
uh profile pictures next to your names
that's kind of nice
elden beast
yeah we're gonna get there in about 30
minutes 30 minutes
that dog was gonna hurt me
what's this
it's a stone sword key right
i'm so smart
i can't use summons so
you're willing to make me a christening
yes
but
a bu
a but a butt
a butt
okay i got a plan
you
three smithing once big big
we'll take rooney boyce we're gonna need
as many rooney boys as we can get
to buy things
those are ruined fragments let's go up
here
give me the item
thank you
that's a five banger
a two banger
a three banger
then we're gonna go down here
i'm gonna beat this bat
next time next week
no i want to go this way right yes
have you beaten the game yet stan
you
come with me
perfect
five smithing ones and a two
that's big
ah
that almost killed me what the heck
all right bruh
we're also gonna get perry from this guy
i think it's 600.
um sure
you got perry hell yeah
and quick step
hell yeah
i'll take both
thanks man
thanks bro
now we need a shield
we can go
where's the uchi katana
wait i need to find the shack and then
i'll know where to go
that's the shack it's this way
which is best one what are you talking
about
which is best of what
be specific
i'm die sure it's right here
yup
i don't need a map
on giga chad
maps are against the rules
i'm not allowed to use a map
imagine
all right we're running through here not
fighting anything
no shot
no shot bucko
i don't know why i'm picking that up
can't use it
no summons
was the hardest boss for you
for whatever reason
still to this day
like oh my god
leave me alone
um morgot
for whatever reason
i struggle with very heavily
you're beautiful
you're beautiful
you're beautiful
it's uchicatana
why am i here
am i gonna get copyrighted
no maps no items no grace no weapons no
hit no ashes no x button no power runs
hey let's give this fight a try like
just for fun
how am i gonna be able to use this later
i'll need some talismans
yeah just for whatever reason morgot
just gave me so much trouble
ow
stop it
that
hurt i just did 29 damage
that is not okay
maybe i can make him bleed or i can come
back because this talisman is good
we get health back on crit hits
i can't put an ash of war on this now
can i wait
it's probably do us better
die
yep
there are so many blood stains in here
yeah for me it's more god's move set is
just so hard for me
i know he's not really all that hard in
general now
he's just a good fight
like i like the fight it's just the
hardest one for me
like i find melania easier than him
ow
that huh
do we know why this guy has like half
health when we enter the fight
it's kind of cool
because i know he's part of the black
knives obviously
faith mage that's a fun build
stop running away from me
it's so cringe bro it's so [ __ ]
quince that you keep running away from
me
oh
so dark
stat
we can definitely beat this guy though
get the talisman that'd be great
no
no
i want his quick step
like his specific one
[Music]
stop it
i rolled
no
oh my god
no
not like this
nah
i'm so scared
what do i do what do i do
i'm going for it
just don't move
nope
i'm going for it again
let's go
big dick talisman
what's in here
oh okay
poggers
i feel i feel very silly today
kind of like it
can be a silly boy today
[Music]
yeah that was close hey look level up
imagine
i imagined it
imagine leveling couldn't be me
okay
do we want this
or this
right now we want this later on when we
have a parry we want that
my ass
i had to scratch it
hold on hold i got a text
old
old okay
didn't expect a messies
what
you know i'm not gonna lie i thought it
was over for us too
hello
chad we have to kill him i have to
murder alexander i really do
i actually have to
hi
i have to pop him out first
is he just gonna die
what up mink
i'm so happy
[Music]
you have a talisman that i need
so i'm like super dead huh
no definitely not
yes your whole existence was a croc
you sucked
we want that though
boost the attack power of skills
i'm sorry chad it had to be done
i had to murder
i had to murder the good boy
okay we need to go back
here
i had to murder him
yeah i didn't realize he was immortal
there
is it weird to say that i feel like i
have a better chance against this dragon
than
the tree sentinel
we're going down below though we're
getting materials
alexander wasn't there in your
playthrough
depends on when you find them i'm pretty
sure
goddamn giga chad looks good today
very pretty
yes
he does have a talisman
which i could have you know
could have done the speed run
or could have done the
quest line i mean
but that takes too
long when things take too long
that's cringe
oh no am i in a cringe mood today
uh oh
i very well maybe
leave me alone i didn't do it
well
that hurt
how many deaths eight
nine
ten
like it don't matter if we die
it don't matter
now they're not aggroed on me
my greatest enemy in every from software
game are rats and dogs
rats
and dogs
yo chill man
this is the boss fight yeah
that's not what we want thank you sir
i like how they're working hard
and i just like
eat it
[Laughter]
what a nerd
okay what do i get from this boss
like nothing right
you get a roar talisman i think
like boost roar attacks which we are not
going to use
so
goodbye
goodbye
my game very very rarely crashed
i think it only happened twice in like
230 hours or something
that's not that's like some crystal
thing
but i still lag to the tree sentinel
imagine
amazing
oh god
ugh dogs
okay the other one is coming
here we go
we've literally conquered the hardest
part of the game right there
we're the best
we the best
music
have a great day at work haku
peace
bye-bye
do you think all of the enemies in elden
rings smell bad
does roar medallion affect dragon breath
that's a good question
i don't know
maybe
i ain't gonna find out
well maybe
okay where's another cave that we can
get materials
or we can go buy some
we can go around stormville that's
actually what we should do
i'm surprised i have a two shacks with
two npcs like kind of right next to each
other here
i'm still not wearing clothes bro
lag
i always lag right in that spot
bum bum
you know these
like old ladies that read your fingers
and stuff
this is what i do this is what i do to
him every time i see him now
they suck
what is this
a cookbook
actually could be useful later
oh we can actually go get a sacred tier
now
i can boost i think i have a golden seed
we're cooking baby
[Music]
die
oh never mind
you get to live
[Music]
nice
should we do the flying glitch
is that against the rules
because i don't think they've fixed that
at all
exactly
who i wanted to see
i've been
testing you
to determine
if the elden ring would truly have you
if you had the metal
to endure this long and odds i don't
know why i'm listening to her
there is but i can take a gathering
plate
let my hand rest upon you for just a
moment
damn i made giga chad kind of hairy
it's got a lot of back hair
how am i going to be able to use the
uchi katana where can i get
11 strength in 15 decks
because i have 10 and everything i need
one more point to strength somehow
which has got to be something out there
that gives me that maybe
[Music]
like a piece of clothing
talisman
same with dex
your new face
play out your arms we'll get smithing
okay
oh
true bill
in fact that's what we're doing right
now and i know how to get there
good [ __ ] bill good [ __ ]
and i don't think we may not need this
right now but we need the source heal
bow show
bow show
i'm gonna get there way faster
yep that's what we're gonna do
we're going right now
oh and i can get the turtle shield
see we're figuring it out
we got this
leave me alone i do not want this
out
ow
oh i'm dead okay almost done
radical sword sale bobby
well yes
stay
run
oh god
i
knew it
those things can smell my under part
i hope they sing for me
they won't though
we can also no we can't
i'm just gonna stop saying what i was
gonna say because it was stupid and
wrong
jesus
english
damn
you think i'm right next to the statue
english please
english
what
i am trying
okay
caleb
so
okay
that's a very deep paragraph
and a weird one
oh i didn't get a sacred tear
i went with
melano instead and get one up here too
unless this is the dragon area
the dragon communion
i don't remember
yep dragon
there anything else here
no
might as well grab it
just in case
bum
oh god
we was like nope
nope
nope
nope
nope
nope
oh i just remembered how to get to where
i want to go
i gotta go back to the
yep
i was kind of running around
not really knowing where to go
but i'm mimba
i'm remember now
blue
does that glitch right there still work
probably but let's not do it
let me jump
been spamming the jump button
nothing oh god
are you kidding
oh
my god
okay there we go
that should open that
okay
okay dude
giga
help
bum bum bum bum
i forget exactly where in this fortress
the radagon seal is but we'll find it
shut up milson
one
two buckle
my shoe
okay
three four
your daughter's a [ __ ]
yeah
somewhere in there
we
what is he yelling at
what
i don't want it
calm down dragon
man
was it that item i saw but can't get to
whoa
crazy
what's this
get the dexes here
i know where to get the other one
cool
i'm scared
oh
wait i'm in the same spot
oh god
i went down the wrong hole
that's what she said
wait what
yep my bad my bad
wrong hole
whoops
yeah they are not singing
are they mad at me
i got what
insta poisoned
i didn't even see a build up
instead
try finger
butt rump
why the heck is there a ladder there
not this
oh
oh i gotta go over there
i gotta jump around i see it
i see it
i see the path ahead
then we gotta go get the turtle
shield
that'll be importante
we can also get some somber stuff here
as well
okay no insta poison this time we'll
take it we'll check it
that's nice
we call that poggers
where i'm
from okay let me grab
got it
how the flip do i get out of here
i don't know
yep i was thinking that too diego
i don't call that cheese
i call it skill
all right whatever
we don't need the runes
yeah
you can upgrade the shield too to make
it better
but it does
basically only
uh scale with
intelligence so it probably won't be
that good
we're just gonna have to get good and
use uchi katana get some bleed off it'll
be fine
we'll try and learn some perry moves
he'll be good
at a running bleed build no is useless
the elden beast is not a hard fight
though
we could probably find some other stuff
to use against him though
or at least i don't find eldon b's hard
yeah we're not talking about defense
though
nope go to the left
thank you
go that way
go
fall
die
oh my god there we go
somber eight
yeah eldon beast is immune to a lot of
stuff
leaf
arc
and a nine banger
okay we want to go
south now
you know what
let's see how big of a difference it is
having a slightly upgraded uchi
and the radagon sourcial on
against uh
our boy here
greatly increases attributes
we can use it
let's go
oh and more heals obviously
we meet again
young lad
yep that's huge
still got to get good though
try rump
yo i wish i could freaking see dude
oh that attack is nuts
this guy bleed
definitely does
yep oh we're gonna die right at the end
no
shot
that would suck
die
rune level one giga chad tree sentinel
down
he has low frostbite resistance though
yes frost is good against everything in
this game
it seems like
and first try
very good very good
i'm gonna kill this guy just to see what
we get because i have no idea
ice greatsword
i didn't even die
you can't give me a death when i don't
die
man that guy sucks
oh you just get bloody fingers
lamp
[Music]
i can't just say i died i didn't die
can we buy
upgrades from this guy i know we can
from the guy in the lake
so i think i need one more uh
smithing two
what's this
sick
um i guess it depends
on what you like
i find frost fun i have like a full
frost uh intelligent strength build
it's fun
no you can't buy anything from this guy
i'm gonna get the crafting kit though
let's go to the one by the lake and we
can get the sacred tier
two
yeah yeah yeah
[Music]
any of you guys watch the body video
lore video yesterday
it's a good video
boom sacred tier boom
then we'll go to call or not kali
another merchant
good video right
i was waiting for his video just to like
make sure that my videos were right
and most of it was
i was happy about that
because there'd be people in the
comments saying like this is completely
incorrect
you're wrong
man
i'd be like i don't think so but
or they'll just be like nothing is
confirmed till body video says
you're unsurprised you know better why
don't
don't like okay buddy
buy them all
nice
and roundtable
doing good
we could go to another mine shaft and
kill a boss at the bottom to get a bell
that we want
because we need more twos
that could be huge for us actually
oh i can put quick step on this
i can do that yet
we need to go get our shield
just for parrying
let's do that real quick that's not
super hard and we can buy more smithing
stones
this
whale
what
you know what i thought was really weird
i feel like toward the end of the game
we didn't really get to use torrent as
much
like
i understand not being able to use
torrent when you're fighting ratagon
but i thought
the like the fight against the elden
beast would have been would have been
way better
way better
if
um
we could use torrent against the elden
beast
what's this
oh determination that could be good
quite a bit of damage
actually don't need that
spoiler alert why are you watching a
rune level one challenge if you're
worried about spoilers dog
i think this is my first rodeo
no
plus the game's been out long enough
we're talking about it
i want to get an explanation for my
first my first litter letter called with
g second r last m
oh george rr martin then dude
bye okay bye
you're lame
lame-o
before she gets turned into a ball
what
also why would someone be watching
any form of elden ring content at all
if they're worried about spoilers
like that's not my fault you turned on a
video or a stream to like watch
something that's so dumb
oh that's a smithing too
mighty shot
i just beat the game yesterday was a
good fight had me rage
yeah it's not an easy fight
like at all
especially when you got to go ratagon
into the beast
very tough
almost leveled
imagine
okay
do i i don't think i have
enough rooney's boys
that should be fine
bullying or ceiling
many as you got bro get one two
we could use some armor
um i want to use the turtle shield
or our parry
[Music]
there it is
oh yeah
oh yeah
looking good
[Music]
we're actually cruising
we haven't really fought anything yet
but doing well
just gathering materials
was here ten minutes ago dawg okay ash
of war on you
perry
great fantastic
do i use determination
it doesn't really
no
i don't think so
no we don't
we can strengthen
one time we still need smithing twos
we could try
do we try market
or we could go get more um smithy
materials
i'm gonna do that i'm gonna get i'm
gonna go get more
because my goal is to try and get all
the remembrances
i should put that in the title yeah
tomorrow
oh i might die here getting this
don't eat it i'm out nope not worth
goodbye
i'm gonna take the telly
the heck is this place
was i going in the right direction
i'm lost
it's too foggy man
i found it
do we want that
what is this down here
i forget
oh yeah we do not need that at all
like not even a little
unless we use carry in retaliation
that's somewhat looking into
it it's good to have it's good to have
i'm trying to gather materials
first sir
first litter called with g second with r
bat last with m i think your english is
way off there dude because that makes no
sense to me
like zero
hmm
three twos
that's big
are you asking why they're like that
george rr martin
the guy who wrote the story
oh
dead
i don't know how good that jellyfish
shield is later
we're gonna use turtle
no more secrets
why not
on a running
i don't know why i'm going to eg i guess
just for like future reference
if i do need eg
but right now i do not
we're gonna get his spot
for later
i don't think i'm gonna get carrie in
retaliation i don't think that's gonna
help us too much later
we'll have to get good with perry
timings and then we'll be okay
well
i presume
oh i am an old cod
perhaps you
yeah those are all sombers
is there a point at making this stronger
not really
because we're just using it for pairing
okay we want to go down there
right wait
tripping tripping slightly we're
tripping
oh god
oh the freaking fall damage with tauren
is so scuffed
[Music]
okay i'm going to ban this guy
some guy on one of my videos just
commented saying
why is everybody so bad at pronouncing
everything in this game it's so annoying
now i'm gonna hide you because you're a
douchebag boom
gone out of my mind
oh that's good bill
good to hear man
thank you i didn't realize that when i
died
okay
i'm being a
dummy thick head right now
it's like
where where's the thing the where's the
big bell turtle
over here
got it
[Music]
did you fall without jumping
okie dokie
[Music]
bond
[Music]
there we go
i think that's a somber in there
we're here for a bunch of materials
and if we kill the boss at the bottom we
get a bell bearing
that lets us buy somber or not sombers
but smithing one and twos
maybe even threes i don't remember
somber two oh god they killed me so
fast believe me be
somber three
finds a good word for it booted
and hi
might die here i die at least once
jumping here every time
nice
nice
no doubts
zero deaths
sarcasm
leave me be
okay we need this though
might be dead i think we're dead i think
we died we're dead
i'm the best
yep
what
you're insane
nope
okay we'll practice
jesus
i'm over it
is my timing just bad
i mean clearly
there we go
[Music]
that wasn't worth it
like at all
we also need to go get my uh physic fizz
wondrous physic flask
wonders physics
oh no
i'm dead
i died
man right before the elevator
these guys are hard to dodge
texting
uh
excuse me
no elevator for me
sad
i won't try to parry some random enemy
ten times
burp attack
oh man
well this is a problem
not as much of a problem now
ah hidden somber boy over here
we do not survive that do we
i do not think we did
we
[Music]
can you imagine running around all over
this world and like bare feet
what up trey
how we doing how we doing
oh
jesus
those hitting my toes
wait a minute
i'm dumb
[Music]
you're gonna fall aren't you
now we send it up
your man key and he's cute thank you
this is giga chad
oh
giga chat strong
giga chat
don't need in there anything in there
yeah i haven't found any clothes yet
that we want to use
we're actually getting some pretty good
progress glenn
what up what up what up
um this could be bad
because we definitely did not need that
ah leave me alone
i don't deserve this
leave me be
okay
we
nerd
okay
oh god we're at the boss fight with no
flash
thanks
let's see how we do
we want to kill this chick for the bell
bearing
i want to get behind her
well
we'll come back
with more
flash
at least we got the elevator this time
this won't this won't be too hard i need
to use the uh
my shield as well
what
we keep it moving
the hating
patrol
are you kidding
okay dude
because i do not have any other weapon
and you'll see
well i have my blunt
thing we don't need it though we're fine
bro
did i just not use the elevator
all right whatever
and then i sent it back down again
i'm all over the place i'm lost
it's all about cracking the shield
with these crystallines and then they're
easy
it's gonna go for backstabs
okay
bruh
these guys are ridiculous
leave me
whew
foreign
up the butt
oh the delayed swings
thought i'd get the backstab
bum
okay
maybe we'll use the blunt weapon
i thought after like two or three
backstabs
her shield would break but it still
doesn't
so i was wrong we'll use the blunt
weapon
this is her
once we break it
we can switch
not gonna be stupid this time
bye ghost
um
okay
ow
right in my elbow
trust me
why didn't none of them follow me this
time
i did use the elevator
i don't know
it's like now is it just better
yep
that hurt
i thought i could hit her
we will only be using the blunt weapon
now
dude
things are crazy man
see now they're following me why
what caused this
oh no
all right we got it this time
what
it's underground oh no
the heavy attack just didn't work
i hit her directly
it did nothing
pain
that's so fast
this
yeah once you break there boys it's easy
i guess i'm just gonna keep getting hit
by those at least one time
what
jeez man
can guys want to kill me so bad
swing again no
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
no
there we go
way
better
put you back on we got our bell bearing
let's get the heck out of here
let's get the heck out of here
okay
back to the round table upgrade
buy everything we need
let's see what we need
to eat
okay
good
boom boom
two more smithing threes can i even buy
those
i think i can
it comes with one or two or two or three
no
okay that's fine
let's go
to
market
see how we do
we're gonna have to learn the pairing
or we could just dodge but i kind of
want to learn the parries
that gets to be too crazy then
we'll see
so i'm pretty sure we could kill marga
and godric
with this setup
[Music]
okay do i have armor of any kind
nope
wow
not a good start
oh
oh that one looked good to me dang it
uses gross fart attack
are you thinking of more got
this is marget who i do not think has a
fart attack
i'm just trying to learn the parries
and make this more fun
perry timings are rough first time
through
hmm
wait
forgot about that attack
oh that looks so good
rest i'd like no music that whole time
my headphones were bugging
perry his hand movement not the blade
yeah it's once i see the timing once
we'll be good
and then i have to get used to the
timings of his actual attacks while
doing it
it's hard takes practice
there we go well
got one
we got one
you have to do it a couple times
to actually get them to stand down
i won't try to do just parries
i do want to learn them
ow
uh
man that one looked good too
was it too early
it's hard to tell
i have to pee
[Music]
one more try then i go pee
these foolish animations go in peace
okay
we go again
keep putting my runes at the back of the
arena
probably should heal but
definitely too early
ah damn
there we go
we got one let's go
progress
well
what parts of his attacks in phase two
can i actually parry
can i parry the like golden sword
i have no idea actually
bump
no jump hmm
yeah that was a little risky
i felt confident though
okay maybe we don't do the parries
they're fun though
that one may not be parriable
not a good start
terrible
the little blade gets me
hmm
[Music]
okay real run just dodging
why is my
my character did not do anything that i
pressed that's weird
my stamina was off
kind of an early stage too
jesus christ
this went nuts for a second
oh holy [ __ ]
man phase two he just goes crazy
not a lot of opportunities
my god
how is that not one
huh
passing skills
tarnished
who hid you
what
i don't know why i'm going for that i
was
silly no
i died of something dumb
nice
wrong shot all right i'm just gonna
you're annoying sorry
wrong chat again huh
so i can't do anything on here hold on
there we go jesus that kid was annoying
i know his english is off but man
he made no sense
to
godric what am i hearing right now
it's like a buzzing sound in that area
that was weird
yeah sorry that kid was getting on my
nerves
still need two threes
looks that might be better than pairing
honestly i don't know how much i want to
parry
we'll keep it though
okay let's go
guess we go in here now yeah
i wouldn't mind some armor
as well i can't hurt can it
not that it matters i think i just get
one shot anyway
come over here
no
no
i refuse
oh god
i just remembered the birds
perfect
might have been better just go through
the main gate to get the godric actually
it won't be that bad
[Music]
out
actually i kind of want to go through
the main gate
okay i think he'd sight on that
is there any other way to the top
without getting the rusty key
don't think so
oh god this is gonna suck
let me heal you're a saint
not bad
oh is this in the corner got it
we
yeah i didn't think there was unless i
went through the main gate then i could
have skipped this entire thing but
that is also hard
little
and hello
um
why am i lagging in here jesus
the frame rate in this game is crazy
aha
what a makeable jump
you know you probably need a running
head start
oh my god it's going to go all the way
down there
no idea why i'm experimenting now
i just ran to the side
go again
it's makable but don't need it
this is gonna suck
cool
oh god i have to go this way
cool
i press the heal button thank you game
roger help me
jesus
ah the pleasure's mine i'm looking for
when i'm not hot food enough about this
place not exactly a plate
i'm here to defeat gadget i see
you can see well i'm tarnished
i'm privy to would you care to learn as
a fellow
hmm
i don't know if this will be those will
be useful to us later
i actually don't know
we'll be fine
why is
that bird is not supposed to be there
at all
dude honestly
main gate would have been way easier
[Music]
you didn't hear that
what does that do
i just saw a chest and went for it
you i turn out in front of everyone here
oh my god
yeah the back way's way better
the front way
leave me alone demon
come on
come on come on come on come on come on
come on [ __ ]
got it
okay
grab a golden seed
that's where nafeli is
i know i can summon her for godric
but not can't do that oh come on
these freaking birds man
they're so stronk
freaking bird
oh my god
come on
jesus
i gotta heal one time
again oh jeez dude
leave me be
i didn't get my runes no it's not like i
need them
okay shield out
we'll be good
again armor would be very nice here
and the birds still there
sick
all right godric
you smell bad
i'm gonna let you know it
huh
ah
did not know that was an attack
[Music]
wham
[Music]
oh i dodged game
don't want to get one shot
level one
nice bro
okay chat
i'm gonna go watch the masters
hope you enjoyed
the first part of the rune level one
series
it's gonna be [ __ ] hard but we can do
it
gonna be a lot of learning
thank you gun
but uh we'll be back tomorrow at some
point maybe even tonight
i might stream again at some point
tonight but
i'm gonna watch the masters
and i hope you all have a great rest of
your day
peace love
all that good stuff
and i'll see you later peace